das ergbt gar keinen Sinn guck mal die
haben alle auch Schwerter wie soll ich
die denn ten oh mein Gott hallo mein
Name ist du meine Damen und Herren ich
versuche heute Minecraft durchzuupielen
jedoch vermehren sich Mobs wenn ich sie
angucke dafür habe ich uns natürlich
direkt eine neue Welt erstellt und ich
würde sagen wir testen das ganz jetzt
einfach mal anhand eines Schafs hier
vorne oh mein Gott wir haben aus einem
Schaf gerade zehn Schafe rausbekommen
geht's auch bei den Mops die ich geklont
habe oh mein Gott was ist den wenn ich
da jetzt eine Minute lang drauf gucke
[Musik]
ich habe keine Ahnung was ich hier für
eine Mod installiert habe so oder so
würde ich allerdings sagen konzentrieren
wir uns jetzt auf das Ziel des heutigen
Videos denn ich möchte Minecraft
durchspielen und ihr wisst dass das
selbst ohne diese Modifikation schon
extrem schwierig für mich ist von daher
craften wir uns hier vorne erstmal eine
Werkbank mit Stöckern und machen uns
dann direkt eine Spitzhacke wodurch wir
uns direkt Steine holen können
[Musik]
oh mein Gott klappt das ganze auch bei
küen oh
[Musik]
moin wir können uns
un Mengen an Essen holen conncrafter hat
den Fortschritt Steinzeit erzielt wow
ich habe mir jetzt erstmal alle vier
Steinwerkzeuge die ich in erster Linie
brauchen werde gecraftet und werde jetzt
einfach mal auf eine Kuh drauf gucken
bis ein paar aneinander sind einf mal
reinschlagen alter das ist ja unfassbar
ich kann mir hier die ganze Zeit
essen holen oh mein Gott mir fällt noch
ein viel verrückterer weg ein wir müssen
eine Kuh hier unten reinschupsen können
die die ganze Zeit anschauen oh mein
Gott das ist so
bodenlos oh mein Gott das ist so
[Musik]
bodenlos oh mein Gott
Alter ich habe instant 24 Leder und fast
ein rinfleisch und fast fün Level wenn
ihr aber denkt dass das jetzt schon
heftig ist dann bleibt auf jeden Fall
dran denn das ganze bezieht sich
natürlich auch auf
Monster das heißt wenn wir jetzt gleich
in der Höhle gehen wird es extrem
spannend ich FÄ hier gerade noch mal ein
bisschen Holz ab weil ich ja noch keine
Kohle habe um das Ganze Fleisch gleich
oh mein
Gott ich bin gottlos ich habe ja leider
noch eine Kohle um das Ganze Fleisch
braten zu können deswegen knalle ich
jetzt einfach ein bisschen Holz rein die
Sonne geht auch schon unter das heißt
ich schaue mal eben kurz dass wir noch
mal eben zu den Schafen laufen oh hier
oben ist ein
Huhn das klappt auch mit
Hühnern ey das ist ja unfassbar ich
hoffe nur dass ich nicht irgendwie
gleich ein Zombie sehe und den aus
Versehen angucke und dann kommen zwei
Zombies dann kommen vier dann kommen
acht oder so haben wir vorne jetzt ein
paar Schafe und können die jetzt einfach
angreifen sodass wir direkt uns gleich
Bett craften können ey das ist unfassbar
ich habe jetzt schon drei
wolle das können wir auch als Taktik für
den Enderdrachen benutzen da ich eine
Menge Leder habe durch das Töten der
ganzen
Kühe ist überhaupt nicht lustig
normalerweise will ich ja auch keine
Tiere töten in Minecraft aber bei so
einem Projekt jetzt heute wo ich halt
einfach wirklich so schnell wie oh diger
die vermehren sich immer weiter ich darf
die nicht angucken ich würde sagen ich
schnappe mir diese sieben Steaks jetzt
mal hier raus und baue jetzt den Ofen ab
nehmen wir die crafting mench auch noch
mal eben mit sagen Tschüss zu den ganzen
güen und wir laufen jetzt einfach mal
hier vorne in irgendeine Richtung denn
hier haben wir direkt eine Höhle boah
das schaffe ich
[Musik]
oder ich bin so ein Gig oh mein Gott es
geht los es geht los wie soll ich h ich
h Zombie ich sehe ein Zombie oh Creeper
was soll ich jetzt machen ich muss sie
doch irgendwie schlagen ich muss die
irgendwie schlagen das war gar keine
gute Idee das war eine ganz ganz
beschissene Idee wie soll ich das denn
jetzt machen wieso oh mein Gott
funktioniert wirklich bei den Dingern oh
mein Gott ich was soll ich tun was soll
ich tun oh mein Gott ich bin tot ich bin
tot ich muss hier raus ich muss hier
raus das ist komplett falscher Weg den
ich hier gerade gehe das ist so dumm ich
muss hier hoch ich muss hier hoch ich
muss hier
hoch klappt es
[Musik]
wirklich
ja oh mein Gott oh mein Gott ich w
runtergeschossen das ergibt gar keinen
Sinn guck mal die haben alle auch
Schwerter wie soll ich die denn oh mein
Gott ach du scheiße das ist doch
unmöglich wie soll ich das denn schaffen
da komm Spinnen ach du scheiße oh mein
Gott wie soll man das denn schaffen
[Musik]
so Freunde habt ihr gerade eine kleine
timelapse gesehen das hier ist mein
neues Inventar ich habe mir jetzt
erstmal schon Ofen zwar gemacht
allerdings jetzt noch nicht mein ganzes
Fleisch gebraten bzw habe ich auch genug
Leder um mir noch mal zumindest kurz
eine Rüstung zu machen ich habe mich
jetzt dagegen entschieden hier wieder
lange Zeit zu warten um
mir ganz viel Essen zu braten weil
vorhin hatte ich ein Deck Essen im
Inventar und es hat mir überhaupt nichts
gebracht weil ich direkt gestorben bin
dementsprechend müssen wir uns jetzt
wahrscheinlich denke ich mal eine Höhle
suchen die nicht wie hier vorne direkt
ein riesen Schlucht aufkommen und
Monster aufkommen irgendwie Preis
hält ist aber gar keiner mehr aber wir
wollen nichts überstützen wir suchen uns
eine kleine Höhle und schauen dass wir
da haben die auch die gleiche Farbe ja
die haben immer die gleiche Farbe guck
mal
hier ist keine Höhle aber wir haben
Kohle unterwassser da habe ich kein Bock
drauf ich bin dann auf jeden Fall noch
ein bisschen rumgelaufen hab Kohle
abgebaut mir ein bisschen Erde geholt
ein kleines Camp aufgeschlagen und dann
hab ein Problem vorne befindet sich ein
Außenposten wodurch wir natürlich
selbstverständlich Gegner am Start
haben die uns warte
[Musik]
mal
oh
wir müssen
tatsächlich
m was wir upgraden unsere Rüstung jetzt
auf jeden Fall erstmal zu einer
eisenrüstung und schmeißen die
Lederrüstung Weg die Sache ist dass wir
auf jeden Fall in die Hölle gehen müssen
um halt Enderman zu töten ze stundnden
später oh mein
Gott ich habe eine riesige Höhle
gefunden
das ist exakt das was wir gerade
brauchen ich würde
sagen wir gehen direkt
[Musik]
runter ach du heilige Mutter
Gottes das ist exakt das was wir gerade
brauchen ganz weit runter und im besten
Fall irgendwo direkt Diamanten kriegen
dann sind wir happy ich sehe nicht mal
irgendwelche Monster
[Musik]
bisher das ist das Beste was un
passieren kann guck mal hier vorne so
ein amethist da sind glaube ich immer in
der Nähe verhältnismäßig öfter
Diamanten hier ist Eisen Eisen haben wir
genug von den
eisengolems ich sehe aber noch keine
Diamanten da vorne geht's weiter da oh
mein Gott es geht los ein Mini Zombie es
geht los ich darf keine Mops angucken
ich darf keine Monster
angucken hier vorne sehe ich noch nichts
an Diamanten oh mein
Gott da vorne sind nch so
leuchtdinger hier geht's auch nicht
weiter aber geht's generell nicht weiter
okay wir müssen zurück hier ist noch ein
Creeper der sich auch vermehrt wenn man
ihn anguckt dementsprechend lassen wir
den da an der Ecke vom Wasser stehen wir
müssen irgendwie tiefer
rein wir müssen weiter runter da vorne
geht's auf jeden Fall lang da ist aber
ein Skelett deswegen schaue ich jetzt
erstmal in diese Richtungen hier geht's
auf jeden Fall auch noch weiter
allerdings sieht das nicht
vielversprechend aus nein müssen zurück
ich glaube wir müssen
wirklich den Weg von dem Skelett lang
gehen hier vorne können wir noch einmal
gucken ich h ein Zombie hinter
mir hier sieht aber auch nicht so groß
aus nee wir müssen in die Richtung von
dem Skelett glaube ich wir dürfen es
aber einfach nur nicht angucken ich habe
ein Schild das
heißt müssen uns auf jeden Fall ein
bisschen darum kümmern dass wir die
Pfeile abwehren und das Skelett in
erster Linie auch einfach nicht angucken
sind aber ganz gut dran vorbeigekommen
da vorne sind ein paar hier vorne geht's
auf jeden Fall weiter nein das ist unter
Wasser
au wir müssen irgendwie Diamanten
kriegen das kann doch nicht sein jetzt
ist der Rest hier alles unter Wasser
oder wie hier vorne geht's auf jeden
Fall noch lang ich werd
runtergezogen oh mein
Gott ich muss einfach tiefer runter
vielleicht war es eine zu große Höhle
für den Beginn aber bisher haben wir uns
relativ gut angestellt was die anderen
Monster
angeht hier ist aber auch wieder nur
Wasser hier ist ein riesen
[Musik]
unterwassersee wir haben großes Problem
mit Diamanten ich tauche jetzt mal hier
vorne
durch und Sch
hier irgendwas zu holen gibt aber es
sieht nicht so aus da vorne ist lisul
nur und hier ist auch nichts hier geht
nicht weiter oh mein Gott ich muss na
vorne ich muss
[Musik]
vorne concrafter wurde der Boden zu heiß
ich
glaube real ich bin der einzige
Youtuber der son
spielt und dann nicht durch die sich
multiplizierenden Monster stirbt sondern
weil der Boden zu heiß wurde gute
Besserung